[Music]
my dad stepped out on his then marriage
and had an affair with my mom um he had
two children at the time so I was raised
as an only child by having siblings and
when I would ask him about it he said
that they didn't want to have a
relationship with me the truth was that
they didn't even know about me U no one
[Music]
did what in the world is going on this
is John with Dr John delone show show
about your mental and emotional
health your ADHD your depression your
anxiety as well as your joy and your
laughter and your warmth and your sleep
and your peace it's about your family
it's about relationships your marriage
your breakups your kids your schools
where you work it's about everything
going on in your life and my promise in
the most in in the most lonely
generation in human history my promise
is I'll sit with you I'll sit with you
and we will figure it out I may not have
the right clinical answer and if I can't
find a buddy of mine who's a researcher
somewhere who's working on some big big
challenges if I can't find the right
person I'll send you to somebody who can
find it but my promise is I will I will
tell you the truth and I won't leave you
alone that sounded weird I'm not going
to like not leave you alone like in a
creepy way I won't leave you all by
yourself how about that is that a better
way to say that today's lyrics will be
Every Breath You Take by the police I'll
be watching you oh man hey the way we
talk about Mental Health
and this is my team this is my tribe
this my gang it's not working it's not
working we've got to change the
conversation here's the question I want
you to ask as we enter into Today's Show
what if what if your body's working
exactly as it should and what if your
anxiety and your depression and your
kids ADHD and your
frustration and that loneliness what if
your body is working exactly as it
should what what would that mean about
what we have to do differently moving
forward and the government's not going
to come save us we're not going to read
some article and some some magazine or
some blog and go oh that's it we're
gonna have to choose to do things
differently and that's what the show is
about it's about making choices to do
things differently at the end of the day
you can only control two things your
thoughts and your actions and that's it
and that's it and that's terrifying
and that's where there's peace if you
want to be on the show go to john.com
askk or go give me a buzz at 1 1844 693
3291 it's 1844 693
3291 building a non-anxious life my road
map on how to build a new life that is
not so burned out not so chronically
stressed not so anxious is out right now
anywhere you buy books you can go to
john.com um I get a few more cents on
the dollar when you do that but I just
want to get this book out to as many
people as possible all right let's go
out to trinton New Jersey and talk to
the mighty Erica what's up
Erica hi hi Dr deloney for taking my
call of course thanks for calling what's
happening yeah uh well first I will
admit I am very nervous and two that I'm
not a longtime listener um I just came
across your Channel about a month ago
and after binging many of your episodes
I thought you know this guy seems to
know a thing or two and I think he'd be
a great person to ask my question to so
appreciate it welcome OPP Welcome to our
gang our our little mad house gang
that's not so little anymore we're super
happy to have you what's up thank you um
okay so my main question is will I
regret cutting ties with my dad um and I
guess some sub questions to like further
discuss or explore would be how do I
find peace with my decision um and if I
don't completely find or feel that peace
is it because it's not the right
choice that's a great question can I
just um answer this off the top of my
head without getting too
deep asking yourself the question am I
going to regret this down the road is
really a recipe for anxiety you're
pre-imaging what the future is going to
hold and you don't know I'd much rather
you ask the question what's the right
decision for me right now that's going
to help me be whole and me be healthy
and me be aligned with my values and my
people
that is a much better question because
here's the deal if you decide for and I
don't even know what the story is on
your dad we haven't even got to that but
if you decide for right now I need to
create some space between me and my mom
me and my dad me and my whoever that's
not a declaration of independence
forever that you're not going to circle
back at some point in your life that
means right now I can't breathe and I'm
around that guy I can't sleep I start
spinning out I I need to make some make
some space and and that's right now and
that could be for the next year it could
be the next five years that doesn't mean
forever so um I I I just the question of
am I going to regret this man I don't
even like that question um because it
just it just assumes that you can read
the future and uh so so what happened
all right um so I guess the backstory
would be um my dad stepped out on his
then marriage and had an affair with my
mom um he had two children at the time
um my parents were never really together
so I was raised as an only child despite
having siblings and when I would ask him
about it he said that they didn't want
to have a relationship with me when the
truth was that they didn't even know
about me um no one did no one on his
side of the that sucks so are you a
product of that Affair yes I said that
so ugly are you a product like you're a
loaf of bread right no um
uh yes okay you're the greatest thing
that ever happened to your mom and your
dad your mom recognizes it and your dad
doesn't so uh and then he lied to you
about your
family yes okay and so you grew up
thinking that your half siblings didn't
like you didn't want to talk to you
didn't want anything to do with you
right um I actually I feel like I spent
most of my childhood feeling as if I was
the one having the affair with him
because I knew very little about him
like I didn't know where he lived he had
told me he lived an hour away when he
actually only lived like 20 minutes away
um I didn't have his cell phone number
like our main form of communic a was
through email and it was like his work
email at that um we'd have to go like
out of town to hang out so that like he
or we wouldn't be recognized and there
were even a couple of times I can
remember growing up like running into
him in public and he would like look the
other way if if he was with his like now
new family hey hey Erica your dad
sucks and and I say that not even
laughing I'm sorry that that was your
dad and let me let me like be as direct
as I
can um I went to hug my seven-year-old
little girl this morning and she did her
Matrix move which she's been doing much
less recently but but I but I grabbed
air I hugged air and she looked at me
with kind of that ha you missed me and I
had to go and I just said hey I love you
and I almost wept on the way to the
car because I can't breathe without my
daughter in the
room and you deserve that
too
and you should have had that I can't
even wrap my mind around seeing my
daughter in a strange place and not
having the entire world stop so I could
drop down and give her a
hug your dad sucks your dad's a coward
an absolute Stone coward and I'm
sorry and I would say that to his face
if he was standing two inches from
me I hate that for you
I hate that for you know what I also
hate it for your mom I hate it for your
mom because your mom um deserved better
than that too yeah and I think she
carries a lot of guilt too feeling like
she put me in that situation no no no no
no well she hooked up with a married man
there's that right and there's there's
consequences from that but I don't like
looking at you as consequences
right yeah like you're a gift you're
here for a reason and you probably do a
lot of good in your local community with
people who love you and people you care
for so I the fact that you're here is
right and
good but your mom can't feel guilty by
saying
hey father here's your baby girl and
expecting him to act like a decent human
being
yeah what a gosh that's that's awful man
I'm sorry I'm
sorry because here's here's what I also
know um I know the downstream ripple
effect of that
is how old are you now 31 a 31y old
woman whose body asks herself every day
what was so bad about me that my dad
wouldn't say I love you and wouldn't
invite me into his life what was so bad
about me and you've probably been trying
to answer that question in some stupid
ways over the years is that fair fair
very fair you're like uh oh
y um yeah it's part of your nervous
system I don't think you I mean you may
have made some choices that may your
life really complicated and hard um but
I'm not even I'll call them stupid
choices but I don't think they were dumb
I think your body was doing what it
could to try to solve the question of
what's so bad about
me and I'll find somebody to love me
I'll find something to cover up that
hurt and that's really hard it should
not
happened okay so how can I help what's
your what's your question about future
regret G so hold on hold on let me let
me do this I'm talking a lot okay is
what I'm saying rink sit with you I mean
does it make sense yeah yeah it took a
few weeks to get to this point with my
uh previous therapist so the fact that
we were able to do that in just a few
minutes yeah I kind of cut through the
first three weeks of therapy
usually yeah um but yeah and so I think
just to kind of like add on to the
backstory which kind of leads to my
question is fast forward to um a few
years ago about 2020 we found out that
he had been keeping another secret and
there was another sibling that we didn't
know about no you mean a pathetic liar
who cheats on his wife has other lies
and cheats that he doesn't tell people
about you know and it's funny because
growing up I would always tell my
younger brother who I do have a
relationship with you know like I
wouldn't be surprised if Dad had another
and then boom it happened I was like I
mean just look at his like patterns you
know yeah Tada the sun came up again no
way all right so you've got other
siblings right and so there's another
one and so despite it being a triggering
situation um I supported him through it
the best way that I could but then I
soon felt betrayed when I realized that
this new sibling had already been
introduced to his family and had been to
his home and I was like wait a minute
like I'm 31 and I still haven't
experienced that um and that became a
pretty defining moment for me and that's
when I decided to completely CTI with
him um but I go back to that initial
question like I often wonder if I me the
right choice um if I'll regret it and or
if I'm even being selfish by not
allowing him to have a relationship with
my family and like specifically my
daughter I'm going to tell you something
really hard I want you to internalize
this deep in your soul okay okay he left
you a long time
ago yeah your dad abandoned you like a
coward and left you the problem is he's
such an extra layer of weak cowardly
man that he left a ribbon out his shut
door for his daughter to hold on
to you ever seen those um they're like
the old science videos that we watched
when we were kids and they're on YouTube
now but you ever heard of like ducks
like baby ducks they imprint and so
they'll have a duck eggs will hatch and
they'll put a big wire like a like a
wire mesh looking duck in the middle of
the room and these baby ducks are born
and they run in and they imprint on that
metal duck they just the first thing
they see that's Mom that's it and
monkeys do that too they have balloons
monkeys that have like uh imprinted on
balloons and the balloon is their mother
and they'll hang out and they'll do
everything with
them your dad did that with a shadow of
himself to
you he left you a long time
ago and if you've listened to the show
if you've done a binge on this show and
talked about um like you hear me say
like I think reconciliation is something
to always strive for almost always and I
think forgiveness is something important
to strive for and I I believe
forgiveness works here too because I
don't want you carrying around his cner
blocks everywhere just forgiveness is
for you it's you setting it down I'm not
carrying this stuff for you old man
you're just you're a disturbed cowardly
man that abandoned his daughter
and um I'm not carrying that
anymore your dad did not leave you
because something was wrong with you
Erica he left you because something was
wrong inside of
him
period I think the thing that feels like
regret is deep and profound
heartbreak and it's right and good cuz
your dad's
awful but the fantasy that he's going to
one day pick up the phone and invite you
to meet your family it's not going to
happen if you want to meet your brothers
and your half brothers and sisters
you're going to have to reach out and
call them and tell
them yeah he's not going to do it you
can't expect a rattlesnake to not bite
you your dad's a coward that's who he is
that's in his DNA he's a cheater he's a
liar that's who he is so he's continued
to choose to
be yeah and I think when I when I cut
ties with him I was making that choice
to not allow him to hurt me anymore and
to just control what I could control and
that doesn't mean you did the right
thing and we often think that if we do
the right thing the world just works out
you did the right thing let me say it
like this you can do the right thing and
it still hurts real real
bad yeah you can end thought I you
thought You' feel a different way right
yeah I thought I would feel peace like
okay like a weight has been lifted off
my shoulder and in no in feel gets
heavier yes and here's but here but
you're you're attributing to something
it's not because you're attributing it
to regret which is you blaming yourself
again which is what little girls do when
their dads abandon
them that weight you feel is
reality he's not going to
call he's not ever going to welcome me
in
that is called
heartbreak and all of the imaginal
imaginative scenarios all of the
Facebook and emails you get back and
forth all the little stolen glimpses you
have all of the little access he gifts
you of his
shadow that's not that's not a
relationship with your dad are you and
so I think what you're feeling deep
inside is oh my gosh my dad left his
daughter do you have kids I do my
daughter can you imagine can you just
just just flip it around can you
imagine just your daughter walks up to
you in the mall and you're just like sh
and you walk away I could never yeah I
don't even I can't even W my head around
that very hard for me yeah it's hard for
me to comprehend that he would do that
my daughter's mean and she doesn't like
me you know what I mean like she's me
and I still I couldn't I can't
imagine that level of Despicable
cowardice I can't yeah yeah but but
that's your world that's that's the
truth
right yeah and I think that in in some
ways um I'm like grieving and mourning
like not only the picture that I had of
what my relationship could be with with
my dad but of him and my daughter cuz I
thought like surely by now even if he
didn't get it right with me he's going
to do it for for her and I realize that
that's not the case and I'm like I
refuse
to I refuse for my daughter to feel what
I did that's right here's here's the
statement where's your daddy my dad's
really
sick his mind and his soul don't work as
they're supposed
to and he's really sick and he had a
hard time telling the truth and he had a
really hard time um with his
babies and it makes mommy sad because I
could never imagine a second without you
in my
life and I think healing for you is um I
would tell you you know what I tell you
I'm going to tell you to to treat this
the same way I would treat you if your
dad had just suddenly passed
away I think it starts with you writing
three
letters one
letter to thank you and I know that
sounds
insane thank you for meeting my my mom
when you did and for having
me cuz if it was a one night stand or a
six-month rendevu whatever I'm
here so thank you for
that the second letter is how freaking
dare
you leave me with a lifetime of
wondering what was so bad about
me and I want you to write that letter
and be bloody honest to yourself honest
to him as though you finally have
permission to say the things that you
need to say and the third letter is Dear
Dad wanted to let you know here's what
you're going to
miss you're going to miss your amazing
granddaughter and as of now you're never
going to see her because I don't have
her around cowardly weak dishonest
unsafe
men
you're going to miss your daughter
growing up to be an incredible woman and
an incredible hard worker and a great
mother and a great wife a great all of
those
things and I wish you the best and you
end the letter with this from this point
forward I'm not carrying you and your
dysfunction on my back
anymore love
Erica and God help you don't send these
letters but I want you to fully
experience them I don't want you to do
it when you have the office plane or or
reruns of some murder podcast plan I
want you to write these when your kid is
with a sitter your kids's at school when
you have some time off work when you can
just fully be present with these letters
and they should be really heavy and
really
hard and then maybe write a fourth
letter to your mom and just say thank
you so so
much
thank you for being a great mom for
showing up continuing to show up even
though you were kicked to the
margins and thank you for being there
for
us and then just enter into a season of
grief shouldn't be this way but it is
start journaling with yourself this is
how I feel today thank God I have my
daughter thank God I have my
mom thank God I have my husband my
partner thank God thank God thank God
next day man today's really
C and then you're going to build a new
picture one that doesn't include
him and maybe one day in 10 years he has
an Awakening a
reckoning and he calls and begs what
have I done I'm so sorry my baby I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry and then maybe you're
whole and you're well and both feet are
of yours are anchored into the ground
and maybe you say I'll meet you for
coffee but if it was me it's for me in
my house
I'd block the
number I'd delete the
email and I would begin to build a world
that already exists in reality and
that's a world without my
dad hate that for you I'm going to send
you building a non-anxious life I think
that might be a great road map for you
to begin to create something new without
him I'm also going to send you own your
past change your future which has a lot
in it about a road map for dealing with
historical trauma and building something
new when everything that you thought was
going to be there for you falls apart
thanks for the call Erica we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey folks Delona here sometimes we
know what's good for us but it feels
like we just can't make ourselves do it
like our brain's getting in its own way
and that happens to me a lot and I'm
pretty sure it happens to you I know I
should play a game with my kids instead
of practicing my guitar all night but
sometimes my brain tells me that hey
maybe that metal band's going to call
after all you got to get your practice
in therapy helps me figure out what's
holding me back from doing what I know I
should do and it can help you too so
your brain can begin to work with you
not against you sometimes it's just as
simple as talking things through and
learning how to intentionally Place
guard rails between yourself and
negative behaviors we call them
boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
license therapist you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge make your brain your friend with
better help visit betterhelp.com dealone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
dealone all right let's go out to NOLA
New Orleans Louisiana and talk to Matt
what's up
Matt Matt you there hey Dr John can you
hear me yeah what's up man oh not too
much all right so I'll get right into it
I I need any kind of advice you can
offer on how to address the issue of my
daughter's mother allowing her access to
a smartphone so I can fill that in a
little a little bit more if you need yes
it sounds like the way you said my
daughter's mother sounds like yall
aren't married yeah yeah unfortunately
we're divorced um my daughter is is 12
uh we share custody and aside from this
one massive issue we seem to be pretty
on the same page as far as our daughter
goes um except for this really one issue
and I've I've tried every kind of
conceivable approach that I could think
of to try to talk with her about it um
explained all of the potential dangers
and consequences of letting a
12-year-old have unfettered access to a
smartphone um there's even been two
incidents that it's already caused uh
one of which was more of a discipline
incident but the second one was um
pretty serious scare where our daughter
was potentially in some serious danger
if I hadn't have caught it um and I
don't know nothing nothing seems to work
to try to get through to her and I'm
just looking for what's her what's her
excuse man what I mean what is her
response when you give her all this info
uh well um the most recent what because
uh the most recent one was just she her
behavior was good and she earned it back
so uh after the major scare I uh agreed
to a we agreed to a compromise where I
did plenty of homework and found a uh
kidsafe phone with with some
sufficiently robust safety features that
I was satisfied with and uh she used
that for a while and then couple of
weeks ago I found out she just let her
have the smartphone back and when I
asked her about it she said oh well her
behavior in school was good so she
earned it um so here's what here's what
you're dealing with you're dealing with
a woman who is so desperate for her kids
approval and so desperate for her kid to
like her
and so desperate to avoid confrontation
with a 12-year-old that she's willing to
sacrifice her psychological well-being
her emotional well-being or her body
image and um her physical and
psychological
safety not to mention um any future
employer who happens to get a written
record of idiotic things at 12 and 13
and 14 and 15 and
16-year-olds say and photos they take of
themselves to boys you're like please
please please please um she would prefer
to be
cool and prefer to be like you you hit
it right on the head because so listen
all of the data in the world doesn't
matter you're not you're not
you look man many many many many people
could solve type two diabetes in 90 days
M they
don't millions and millions of people
could lower their risk of lung cancer by
quitting smoking they
don't you're not dealing with an
information um deprivation you're
dealing with a very insecure adult who's
allowing the her 12-year-old daughter to
prop up her emotional
regulation and I hate that for you yeah
so I would stop going to war with with
my ex-wife because you're not it's
there's no one wins this
yeah I would do the best I could to put
those little I Spy Apps I don't know
what they're all called where you can
see your where your daughter's going
maybe but that's I mean that's a losing
proposition kids are just too smart oh I
I I fully understand that one um and I
also say this
um
my my son most of his friends have
phones yeah and when they come to our
house we don't allow kids to have phones
and there's this really rad thing all
the parents are all in all of them when
they walk into our house they hand my
wife their smartphone and my wife just
puts it keeps it and tells all the
parents if you all need one of your kids
text me and I'll I'll get them and the
parents love it and you know who else
loves it the kids love it so yeah when
she's at Mom's house she's got her phone
she's at your house there is no phones
period
mhm and she she will kick and scream
because those things are so addictive
and they are their Lifeline to their
friend communities and they are their
Lifeline to everything and the parents
are adult the adult world has failed
these kids but that's where we are and
so just prepare for her to be mad but
she's not mad at you she's mad that her
body is screaming at her because you've
cut off her Supply yeah okay yep and by
the way when she's over with you you're
going to to put your phone away
too absolutely I hate this for you
dude yeah yeah I mean I I think it goes
without saying that my my biggest fear
is that it's going to take something
massive happening before you know the
realization hits that oh this this is a
bad idea I actually don't think that
would solve
it because you can look at the child
predator um numbers in this country and
the sex trafficking numbers in this
country and how quick um Predators just
swarm like ants to chat rooms with 12
and 13 and 14 year old girls doesn't
matter parents don't care they still
hand their kids phone it's insane it's
insane absolutely I I work I I I deal
with that in my line of work so I I'm
very I'm very familiar with with all of
it
yeah man okay yeah there's not a thing
man there's just I mean it your daughter
could get I don't want to I don't put I
don't want to put things out into the
universe your daughter could get way
over her head yeah and she would have
the phone back and four
months three months yeah that that's
basic that's basically what happened I
mean what did she do if you don't mind
me asking I mean she was in serious
danger of getting groomed she was
talking I caught her talking to some
stranger that she met online that
claimed to be claimed to be a boy her
age but you know how that works um
fortunately uh she she didn't send any
kind of inappropriate pictures or
anything like that but uh this time I
mean it was the it was there was classic
groomer style language and and there
were pictures that were sent to her of
supposedly the person she was talking to
that was pictures of a young boy but I
mean you know you know how that works
yeah but here's the thing already
stamped inside of
her
um already stamped on the inside on the
inside of her chest right by her heart
is how alive she felt when that boy that
fake boy was telling her how pretty she
was and how smart she was and there will
come a moment when she's 16 that she
goes chasing that again yeah and she
might not send photos when she's 12 but
she's 16 it's a different game she's 17
that's a different game she's 18 that's
a different game and moms and dads if
you think I'm
playing I've just done too many sexual
assault investigations at the University
level I've had sat with too many young
college students who explain to me what
happened to them in high school I'm
telling you and you keep doing it anyway
you keep doing it anyway dude now you
got me all fired up man oh yeah yeah I
mean like I said I deal I deal with it
almost every day in my line of work uh I
deal with you know that kind of stuff so
I'm well familiar with with all of it
and so that's why it's my that's my
biggest fear she's going to be here's
the workaround there's not a workaround
here's the reality that you have to
choose to live into okay okay it means
sitting down with your 12-year-old
daughter and being incredibly
explicit if somebody asks you to take a
picture of yourself don't and please let
a grownup know and if you don't trust me
and you don't trust your mom trust Miss
so and so I actually told my daughter
the other day I have kind of a I don't
want to say frequent but a quiet
check-in just as using professional
skills I just happen to be her dad but I
said and you remember if you don't want
to tell me and Mom you can tell Miss
Beth you can tell Miss Rachel and
my daughter said ah Dad I
know but I think you sit down and be
very clear about hey honey I deal with
my
job old men trick young girls into
sending pictures of them without their
shirts on without their clothes
on and it feels scary and it feels
exciting and it
feels a little bit dangerous and it's
really really
scary never even if you know that's your
boyfriend on the other line he can
screenshot that photo maybe show her an
example of a screenshot and he'll have
it to show his friends forever never do
that please never do that and I think
you have to get very very explicit
obviously she's 12 so be age appropriate
don't be a weirdo but um I think that
explicitness moves up uh it becomes
increasingly more direct as she gets
older um as she has to e8th grade in
high school and Beyond but dude I'm
sorry I'm sorry your wife's not not like
no way I didn't know that she knows she
knows she's too insecure to look at her
12-year-old daughter and say I'm your
mom and I love you so much I refuse to
open the hounds of hell inside your
house and inside your bedroom and inside
your head I'm not going to do it my
job's to protect you instead she handed
her phone said here's every creeper in
the world on planet Earth best of luck
to
you unbelievable man sorry Matt sorry
jez Louise we'll be right
back what's up friends Dr John deloney
here and I want to let you in on a
secret that most people didn't tell you
before you got married honesty and
intimacy take practice they don't just
happen you got to put the Reps in and a
beautiful weekend away in Nashville
Tennessee is a great way to do just that
so join me and Rachel Cruz right here at
the Ramsay Event Center for a money and
marriage getaway you'll learn how to
have healthy conversations around money
boundaries and even sex and Intimacy in
your marriage plus we're going to have
an incredible great time this weekend is
for couples in every season of life and
engaged couples are welcome too but it's
coming up fast October 19th through the
21st it's a 3-day Retreat the cost is
799 bucks but you can take a $100 off
when you use the code deloney at
checkout that's three Incredible Days
for you and your spouse for just 699
bucks
go to Ramy solutions.com getaway today
that's Ramy solutions.com
getaway all right we're back let's go
out to Seattle home of Sound Garden in
Nirvana and talk to Claire what's up
Claire hey how are you partying dude
what are you up
to oh you know oh you know just Seattle
in it up is it raining
today it is actually for the first time
in a while so if you you could do me a
huge favor and go holler at your
baseball team tell them to just take 30%
off and back it down a notch my Astros
are in danger of not making the playf
because your boys came out of nowhere so
just send a nice note and tell them to
just chill out okay what's
up so I've been listening to your show
for a while and I guess I've heard you
talk to several people about I guess
um living in a fantasy when it comes to
I guess except the reality of the person
that's right in front of you and I
wanted to talk to you a little bit
about if I'm doing that or if I'm seeing
the potential in somebody and supporting
their growth in life in in the context
of a romantic relationship sure tell me
more I something happened and that's why
you called what
happened well you know we've been dating
for two years now and
from the beginning I knew that you know
he's prone to a lot of anxiety and
depression and when he's really feeling
those things it's like this Dark Cloud
that follows him around you know he's
quick to anger he's super defensive he
can be really cold and like just
negative and it seems sometimes even
like suspicious of me that I'm going to
hurt him you know in some way when I'm
just trying to be caring
and on the other side of that when he's
not feeling that you know everything is
so great he's playful and loving and I
feel so cared about
and and he's I've really encouraged him
to seek help um and he's been going to
therapy and I feel like things
have I guess gotten better but you know
I'm I'm also particularly
sensitive person and so you know if he's
short with me I it just feels so heavy
sometimes and I'm like man is this going
to be is this am I gonna is this going
to be like this
forever and sometimes I it just feels
overwhelming and I think do I just need
to accept
this is who he is is like a cold short
person
or am I actually like investing my time
and energy into helping him grow and
build a
relationship does that make sense yeah
totally
um can I say a couple of hard things and
you push back if I'm wrong yeah think of
me like you're at the doctor's office
and it's like does it hurt here does it
hurt here that's what I'm doing right
now
okay
um I think there's something
else what's the something
else um I guess I I don't know if
there's anything else how how dark are
those dark
moments I
mean I guess what bothers me the most is
like he'll when he's angry he raises his
voice and
sometimes he'll swear and that's really
triggering for me yes so here's that's
what I was getting
at it's not a matter of him having
anxiety it's not a matter of him having
depression I know loads of people myself
included who have those traditional
Diagnostics that have great
relationships but they're a context
they're not an excuse to scream and
swear and cuss at somebody you love
and Beyond the raising your voice and
swearing he scares
you yeah and so I just tell you my
house well let me even before I even
tell you about my house I don't want you
to look at this relationship like it's a
bank account that you're trying to
invest over the Long
Haul like he's not a he's not a mutual
fund yeah the question you need to ask
yourself is do I feel safe and loved and
seen and heard and still loved anyway in
this
relationship not if I do a bunch of the
right things and keep pushing him and
grooming him and codling him Anda for
the occasional like oh you're great for
that occasional ray of
sunshine in the next 15 years will this
finally all go away the answer is
no yeah because he's not a mutual fun
in my house my wife and I came to the
understanding that my refusal not to not
be anxious because that's just my body
trying to get my attention not to be
running really low that was my body
trying to get my attention but my
unwillingness to go way upstream and
change the way I do
things um that was the
problem and so when we sat down and said
hey if we're going to both feel safe in
this relationship if you're going to be
the man that I know you can be and I'm
going to be the most plugged in wife
that I want to be um here's what I need
from you and it wasn't to not be anxious
it was I need you to take care of
yourself I need you to put the computer
down I need you to sleep I need you to
never scare me in my house right and and
she didn't say all those things I'm just
I'm speaking in her language um into
your home home MH the conversation is if
he won't go do the things he went to
counseling which is great that means
he's sitting down talking to somebody is
he then going to the
gym is he then going to work a second
job to pay off what he owes is he then
going to do these things that's going to
give him peace in his
home that's the bigger
question
what say
you well um I don't know that's a lot it
is it is how how about this have you
been completely clear and honest and
direct about what about what you need
what you want and what your boundaries
are yes I feel like I have them okay
have you enacted those boundaries for
instance if you yell and and swear at
me you are through your behavior kicking
me out of my own house and I will
leave or kicking me out of the
apartment and I will
leave well I'm just having a low episode
you don't even care no no no no no no no
your low episodes are not an excuse to
treat me like garbage if you're having a
low episode it's your responsibility to
step out go get the help you need go get
the care you need go do the things that
help you be well and whole be honest
with me
yeah not use me as a as a living
embodiment of a Xanax to try to make you
feel better that's not my
job yeah and that's what I worry about
because I put so much responsibility on
myself to try to I guess soothe him that
it weighs on me yeah because you're his
mom
now yeah you're like a pet owner you're
a mother you're not a
girlfriend is that fair
yeah yeah like there's no such thing as
a perfect person and there's no such
thing as the one those are all Hollywood
myths so it's not real it's actually way
before Hollywood but they're not that's
not real the question you have to ask
yourself is is this person doing
whatever they can to help me meet my
needs so that I can do everything I can
to help meet their needs so that they
can do everything right are we both in
this together so we can build something
amazing or yeah am I still on the road
trying to change tires
and when I talk about like a
fantasy somebody sits down and says hey
John I've got this idea for a
business the idea for a business is um a
group of
people um everyone people are going to
have cars and they're just going to be
connected on their cell phone and you're
going to be able to just hit a button
and that person who's closest to you is
just going to swing by and pick you up
and we're going to handle money over
here electronically so there's not even
an exchange of money you don't even tip
in person and um I'll do a whole bunch
of background checks on the person over
and over and over again to make sure
they're safe no more taxis no more you
having to park downtown no more any of
those things you just hit a button on
your phone someone's going to swing by
and pick you
up if someone explain that to me that'd
be awesome i' I can see how that could
work really
great there's going to be a lot lot of
Regulation a lot of things we have to do
to get there but I can see
it and when my daughter brings me her
wooden helicopter idea built out of a
out of a like some sticks and a chair
and some rope I can see
it I can also
see sh that's not going to
work
yeah so let me ask you a hard hard
question are you done and you're just
trying to give yourself permission to be
done cuz your Roi language suggests I
heard a comedian say the other day the
worst part about a long-term breakup is
you get no future credit for that in the
new relationship you can't be like you
can't meet somebody new and be like no
no no no I already went to all the
weddings like I did that like you got to
go to the other weddings now right you
got to do it all over again um and
somebody with an Roi mindset sometimes
find themselves in relationships long
term that they should have left a long
time ago um but they've deposited so
much in the account they don't want to
lose that sunk
cost yeah are you done
I sometimes in those moments
when they're low I feel like that but
another issue I guess is that I don't
really trust myself to make that
decision because I've had a tendency to
run away when things are hard before
okay I love that I do
too I have a bad tendency to cut and
run in fact one of my mentors told me
once he said the worst thing you've done
for yourself is giving yourself so many
options you got so many degrees and so
many credentials and so many experiences
that you can just cut and run and you
never have to live through something
when it's hard and only when you put in
the work during the hard season do you
get this amazing Harvest on the back
end but if you cut and run and every
time you show up it's just when they're
picking the apples and you don't like to
sit there through the drought man you
don't get to see the super Harvest in
the back end and he was right he was
absolutely right I cut and run and so
what I've learned to do is I Outsource
that before I quit my job as a senior
student affairs officer I flew across
the country sat down with two of my
oldest buddies and said I'm thinking
about quitting all this to become a
podcaster and a YouTuber does that sound
smart and they were like you're nuts and
that sounds
right like you're going to get to travel
around and speak write books get on the
road help people it's nuts but it's
right right I was too close to
it yeah do you have some women in your
life that know what you've been going
through know your boyfriend know how you
your tendencies that you could sit down
and be completely honest
with yeah I
do would you be willing to honor them
and you by saying hey I need yall for
three hours on Saturday morning I'm
going to lay this all
out and let them speak into your life a
little bit yeah I can do that I think
that would be awesome at least give you
some clarity and tell I promise I won't
get mad and I won't do classic CLA or I
try to overe explain myself or whatever
your classic moves are um yeah but give
them permission I'm not seeing this
clearly um and I talked to this goofball
podcaster and he suggested that I get a
different opinion from people who love
me but I think that's where you're at
here's here's my super fear I think in
your gut you
know and maybe you spent a lot a lot of
years learning to shut that inner voice
up or maybe this is the time too your
inner voice is wrong either way I think
you
know question
is do you all agree about the need for a
change and are you both taking steps
however wobbly or wonky towards those
changes towards that new tomorrow
and if you're doing that and you're in
then that's
awesome my wife has been there for me as
I have had to completely relearn how to
be a grown-up and I've probably done
that three or four times and I've been
there with her when she's made her
changes that's the nature of
relationships but it all starts with an
agreed upon here's what I want this
house to feel like here's what I want my
marriage to feel like I want it to be
warm I want it to be hilarious I want it
to be safe I don't want to walk into my
apartment and feel scared that I don't
know what mood you're going to be
in I can't control that I know you're
right so your work is how do we get way
Upstream of that and begin the healing
process
there cuz you deserve somebody that
doesn't scare you somebody that doesn't
swear at you somebody doesn't scream at
you you deserve that regardless of what
they're diagnostic
[Music]
is let me know how that that
conversation on Saturday goes i' would
love to get some feedback on that and
let let let me know what those uh women
you trust
say but I think you
know we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right we're back with a new
installment of am I the problem is it me
go for it Kelly all right so just as a
reminder email us your email your
questions if you have a question want to
know if you're the problem send them in
make them short we'd love to read them
okay all right hi John my name is Nicole
and I have an issue and I've been told
that I am being
unreasonable I'm getting married early
next year and I have five bridesmaids
I'm getting some Flack from a few of
them over the cost between the dress
Bachelorette weekend showers hair and
makeup and travel to the destination
wedding it will be between $4 and $5,000
per person good God I don't think this
is too much to ask since these are my
best friends it is it is then you pay
for for it a couple of them want to drop
out because they say they can't afford
it yes I don't think this is unfair to
ask it is please John please tell me
that I am not the problem you are 1,000%
the problem you and everybody else who
expects your friends to Shell out
$55,000 for you to live out your fantasy
yes think about this what if all five
bridesmaids just wrote you a check for
$5,000 you'd have 25
Grand yes yes and yes but how do I do it
that's ridiculous I don't know here's
how my wife did it she asked all of her
friends will y'all buy yourselves a New
Dress whatever y'all want something that
you'll wear again and so our pictures of
our wedding everyone had different
things on and I was going to wear khakis
in a white dress shirt and all my
groomsmen were like you look like an
idiot and so they decided what they're
going to wear and I went along with
it you know we didn't have any stress
and they were had to to come many of my
buddies had to come eight hours away
from where they all lived and so I was
responsible for their housing and the
housing wasn't great so their sacrifice
wasn't 5,000 bucks as they all crammed
into one of my buddy's houses and
there's a lot of shenanigan stories
about that one whoa but that's what they
did I don't know am I crazy Oh no you're
100% on Brad the whole way and granted
I've been married for almost 20 years so
it wasn't quite this bad when I got
married but the idea of the bachelor
weekend I even had a friend that was in
a wedding and this was a family member
of hers there was a color scheme a
palette that they all had to buy clothes
for the bachelorette party to match this
color palette so that all the pictures
they all stop doing life for freaking
Instagram quit quit doing life for your
dumb photo album do life cuz it's
awesome cuz you want to make memories
with your friends my gosh what is wrong
with us a color palette if I handed my
buddies a color palette I would not go
to the bathroom yours would just be
black for years you know why because it
would be shoved so far up the that it
would I mean you've got to be color
palette what are we doing this is your
life and it's ending one friend at a
time and what bothers me it's not about
their marriage this is all about the
wedding yes and I'm all about a
beautiful nice big wedding I love that
awesome awesome but be respectful in
these this day and age asking a bunch of
25 and 30 year olds to come up with
$5,000 good God Almighty that's a lot of
money yep congratulations Nicole you are
the problem Jenna am I crazy you're
younger than no you're not crazy that's
100% true I mean I got married a couple
years ago and it was like I had my
bridesmaids pick like lowbudget dresses
I even paid for some of their flights to
fly out to see me for our bachelorette
party like I covered a lot of the
expenses for them because I don't want I
don't expect them to just drop thousands
of dollars on my wedding that just seems
ridiculous it's not you know why cuz it
is people have lost your minds listen
it's about it's about your marriage
and yes I love a good party more than
anybody it's about your
marriage color
pallets I can just imagine like a group
if there's ever a draft for a new world
war that there's a group of folks lining
up in front of like the wings in
Nashville and it's like we got to get
our the color pallets right before we
get shipped off what are we doing what
are we
doing thanks Kelly I'm going to be all
bad mood McGee for the rest of the day
this had the exact outcome that I wanted
it to have I love you guys
[Music]
bye